the Lord of the Rings trilogy has become
so ingrained in popular culture that
it's difficult to imagine how it might
have looked with a different cast but
several notable actors turned down big
roles here are some of the names who
could have resided in Middle Earth
according to reports Sean Connery was
offered the role of Gandalf before it
went to Ian McKellen Peter Jackson was
apparently so keen on Landing the former
Bond actor but he convinced new line to
offer Connery a 15 slice of the box
office takings plus a 30 million dollar
pay packet the Lord of the Rings trilogy
made just shy of three billion worldwide
so it was a pretty costly decision
especially when you consider the fact
that Connery went on to star in the
career ending the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen instead so why
did the iconic Scot turn down the chance
to play tolkien's most famous wizard
ah I'll take swords for 400. in 2012 a
retired Connery admitted that he said no
to the Lord of the Rings because he just
couldn't get his head around the
sprawling Story the actor said I read
the book I read the script I saw the
movie I still don't understand it Ian
McKellen I believe is marvelous in it
when McClellan was asked about Jackson's
pursuit of Connery during an interview
with total film he joked that the films
would have been quote very different had
Connery chosen to take on the role
saying Gandalf would have come from
Scotland for a start you shall not pass
doesn't have quite the same ring to it
does it stay back if you value your life
Christopher Plummer grew up reading the
Lord of the Rings and has admitted to
being a huge fan of tolkien's world but
he still chose to turn down the
opportunity to play Gandalf when Peter
Jackson Came Calling years later the
actor revealed that he had an issue with
the level of commitment required for
plan spending three years in New Zealand
at his age just wasn't an option he
explained to Conan O'Brien I thought
there are other countries I'd also like
to visit before I quote he added that
the quote absolutely marvelous Ian
McKellen brought a warmth to the wizard
that he himself may not have been able
to produce I might have been a little
cold and imperious plumber has still
done some memorable work since passing
on rings not that he had anything left
to prove after carving out his
illustrious career he was nominated for
a prime time Emmy for playing Cardinal
Bernard law in the Catholic Church abuse
drama our fathers in 2005 and in 2012 he
scooped up his first Academy Award
triumphing in the best supporting actor
category for beginners his win made him
the oldest actor to take home a
competitive Oscar Plummer almost beat
his own record in 2018 when he was
nominated for all the money in the world
a role he famously took over for a
scandal hit Kevin Spacey at the last
minute but he was beaten by Sam Rockwell
for three Billboards outside ebbing
Missouri Peter Jackson is said to have
attempted to convince Daniel Day-Lewis
to take on the role of Aragon on
numerous occasions supposedly the
three-time best actor winner repeatedly
spurned his advances according to the
One Ring which had the inside track on
all things the Lord of the Rings back
when the trilogy was still in
development in October 1999 A source
told the Tolkien fan site that producers
had made one final push to get Day Lewis
on board stating gdl has been offered
the Aragorn role again he has been
offered the Middle Earth to take the
role The Producers think he'll say no
again but they don't want to miss the
chance to try him
Jay Lewis addressed the long-running
Aragorn rumors over a decade later
confirming that he was indeed offered
the part speaking to MTV's Josh Horowitz
in 2009 the notoriously picky method
actor said that he rejected the role
because big franchise films just aren't
his bag he explained they can be
fantastically entertaining for the
people who love to see them but it's not
for me if I found myself working on a
film and during the course of that work
I was bored because I didn't really know
what the hell I was involved in I would
find that infinitely demoralizing and it
might well make me decide to pack my
bags Day Lewis retired from acting in
2017. the idea of Nicholas Cage playing
Aragorn might sound like nightmare fuel
but believe it or not this almost came
to pass cage was a headliner at the time
Fresh Off starring roles in Conair
Face-Off and snake eyes
no yes no come on this is not fair man
come on
taking the lead in a big budget epic
like the Lord of the Rings would have
been the next logical step for him but
he was forced to turn down Peter
Jackson's offer because he had quote
family obligations that he couldn't
ignore it wasn't the only huge role he
passed on either cage also said no to
the Matrix the actor said both are great
movies but they both shop for great
quantities of time I mean years
Australia was The Matrix and New Zealand
was The Lord of the Rings cage expanded
on his explanation during a 2015
interview with Newsweek where he said of
The Lord of the Rings there were
different things going on in my life at
the time that precluded me from being
able to travel and be away from home for
three years
he has absolutely no regrets however
saying I get to enjoy the movies as an
audience member because I don't watch my
own movies had his schedule been
different perhaps the state of his
career today would be different too For
Better or Worse cage was unable to take
the part and we're left wondering what
bizarre accent he might have given the
future king of Gondor by the time New
Zealand native Russell Crowe was
approached about the Aragorn vacancy the
Lord of the Rings budget was starting to
look a little stretched they didn't have
enough cash to give Crow a suitable
upfront fee so producers offered him a
percentage of the takings instead it
wasn't enough to tempt him though years
later Crow conceded that it would have
been a risk well worth taking in 2011
the actor delivered a lecture about his
career in the business to film students
at England's Durham University according
to the telegraph Crowe talked about
turning down the Aragorn role joking
that he wouldn't have needed to do paid
appearances had he agreed to newline's
offer of 10 of The Lord of the Rings
prophets so why didn't he Crow didn't
reveal the reasoning behind his costly
decision until 2019 when Howard Stern
decided to probe him about it I didn't
think Peter Jackson actually wanted me
on the film because I think he was
forced into talking to me because there
was a moment in time when any everybody
wanted me and everything Crow knew that
something wasn't right when he spoke to
Jackson over the phone about the part
though he said he had an instinct
Jackson wanted someone else for the part
Viggo Mortensen Kate Winslet started
getting linked with a possible
appearance in The Lord of the Rings as
soon as new line announced that Peter
Jackson was going to spearhead its
ambitious three movie Project the
director gave the British Starlet her
big break when he cast her in 1994's
Heavenly Creatures a psychological drama
based on a famous New Zealand case
involving two teenage killers by the
time Jackson started casting for the
Lord of the Rings Winslet was a huge
star having been nominated for Academy
Awards in the best supporting actress
and best leading actress categories for
1995's Sense and Sensibility and 1997's
Titanic respectively
she had her pick of projects at the time
and the Lord of the Rings just wasn't
appealing enough
Winslet was reportedly offered the role
of Rohan shield made in eowin but she
had some commitment issues according to
an email allegedly written by former
newline Cinema president of production
Michael DeLuca the supposed email which
was forwarded to the Lord of the Rings
fan site the One Ring by an inside
source read Winslet's unavailable I'm
afraid I think she passed on the project
due to the length of time it takes some
people might view that as a gross error
of judgment on Wednesday's part but her
career didn't suffer as a result she's
been nominated for another four Oscars
in the years since winning one
Uma Thurman certainly has a high fantasy
look about her it's easy to imagine the
actress as Galadriel but that's not the
part that Peter Jackson had in mind for
her the director wanted Thurman to play
aeon the same character that Kate
Winslet was approached about Thurman
also turned the part down though unlike
Winslet it wasn't just a Time issue she
and her then husband Ethan Hawke had
just welcomed their first daughter Maya
when the offer was made presenting the
new mother with a difficult choice in
the end Thurman decided to put Family
First and reject Jackson's overtures
though she later admitted that the
decision still haunts her she confirmed
to MTV in 2008. yeah I was asked it just
caught me at the wrong moment I wish I
had done it oh I truly wish I could have
been able to take that plunge and maybe
I should have but I just couldn't at the
time when she appeared on The Late Show
with Stephen Colbert almost a decade
later
the Kill Bill star admitted that
rejecting the Lord of the Rings was
quote one of the worst decisions of her
entire career I just had my first child
and I just I don't know I was a little
housebound
at one stage husband and wife team Uma
Thurman and Ethan Hawke looked set to
appear in The Lord of the Rings together
with the latter confirming his planned
involvement at the Toronto Film Festival
Hawke not only revealed that he would be
playing boromir's younger brother
faramir a role that eventually went to
Australian actor David Wenham he also
let slip that tolkien's enigmatic
supporting character Tom Bombadil had
been cut from the screenplay the actor
went on to gush over the author's work
claiming he had been a fan of the
Tolkien series since childhood despite
his obvious excitement Hawk pulled out
of the pitcher perhaps leaving his wife
at home to care for their newborn
daughter after she had turned down a
part in the same movie wasn't an option
for the actor who takes Parenthood so
seriously that he was inspired to write
a book about it his now ex-wife has
admitted that she regrets rejecting the
Lord of the Rings but does Hawk feel the
same he didn't explicitly say that he
wished he had taken the faramir role but
when he sat down with Variety in 2018 he
revealed that he was still waiting for
his big Blockbuster moment saying before
I die I would really like to give a
meaningful performance inside a really
commercial film Lucy Lawless is best
known for starring in the much-loved
Xena Warrior Princess the New Zealander
seemed to be the perfect fit she had
plenty of fantasy experience and the
kind of flawless features that Galadriel
is known for in the novels but it wasn't
meant to be
sometimes people do things that they
regret Lawless was pregnant when Jackson
approached her about the role and the
director clearly failed to sell the Lord
of the Rings to her because she forgot
to turn up for the audition in a 2003
interview with hot celebs magazine
Lawless revealed that she also turned
down a chance to appear in Fox's
franchise opener X-Men at the time
despite knowing that she probably
wouldn't get another shot at the big
leagues she said you know what might
happen by the time I'm ready and want to
do a multi-year contract they won't want
me but what can I do I've turned down
great things it's not worth it if your
children are miserable
her prediction came true and although
Lawless is still working today having
starred in the Australian crime series
my life is murder in 2019 and voiced an
alien queen in two 2020 episodes of Star
Wars resistance her career could have
been a whole lot different if she had
agreed to portray tolkien's telepathic
elf check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more Looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]